[Music]
when you guys were teenagers the male's
in here
yeah masturbated a lot eat a lot foods
all the time I do ladies and gentlemen
my question is when you guys war between
the ages of 14 and 24 were you a big fat
wet t-shirt contest I loved it you're
significantly low in confidence levels
were to the point where you would rather
be single than to ask a girl out I just
thought about this tip because the other
day I was like you know
do you remember show-and-tell yes I
couldn't [ __ ] wait to go to
show-and-tell like I would look for [ __ ]
- [ __ ] display and like talk the
whole [ __ ] class no but here's the
[ __ ] thing though there was a period
in between junior high to high school
and around there where I was afraid to
talk in front of people what about your
confidence in front of girls girls that
you liked I did too horny she gets very
that's not confident would you ever
either be stay single and not approach
someone during that time no no no I
always I guess so horny that I need to
talk to her I didn't I faced I never had
a problem but maybe middle school like
like you the awkward - you - three years
that was a little bit maybe [ __ ] up
for me like when it came to my emotions
and [ __ ] but after that I never had a
problem part I always have to talk to
girls and I'd rather do it and get
rejected then to live with the feeling
of [ __ ] I never told her if I couldn't
do it I begged my friend to do it for me
there you go tell her that I [ __ ]
love that and that's the thing - and I
also liked gross from a very young age I
remember being in [ __ ] kindergarten
be like I love oh yeah I remember one
time in high school this girl I liked
her in elementary and then I went to a
different junior high and I saw her
again I was like it's her and now she
has to tease and I [ __ ] need to talk
to her and I was like what should I do
and in my friends like just [ __ ] get
her number man and you guys could talk
every day
and I was like oh my god what do I say
you'll just ask her for her number so
she was talking with her friend
I went up that high it's like would you
like to talk on the phone sometime and
her friend was like and I'm like I'm not
shake and she's like yeah and I was like
okay thanks and then she's like you got
anything to write on and I was like and
I was like looking at you're at school
you should have [ __ ] Cerreta I didn't
[ __ ] have books and anything he's the
guy like Wohlers a pencil for men
exactly never gives a back [ __ ] ran
up to somebody on in the hall and I was
like yeah a pen and he goes yeah and I
grab this pen and I [ __ ] got it and I
was like alright and then she's like you
have anything oh right oh my god I like
here and then she [ __ ] wrote it on my
arm right and I was [ __ ] shaking like
this and her friend was like and then we
talked on the phone every smash there's
a smash
now I was like in ninth grade so did you
smash I was make Ida problem making
moves on girls though well girls was
easy but the making a move part was I
didn't even realize until later on how
how how easy I probably had it in the
moment but I didn't make the move you
mean like you friend-zoned yourself I
yeah kind of but but I would just not
like I think it was an expectation of
like yo like you why aren't you kiss me
yet and I was just like being cool and
gentlemanly like I'm like that too and
that's okay right it's just something
that I realized later I was like oh my
[ __ ] god and when I go through my
memory bank I'm like oh my god you left
so much on the table what are you an
idiot cuz the core alleged well no no no
doubt but but it's crazy to think about
those moments where I was definitely an
idiot and that girl's point like wow oh
yeah I've always liked women always you
always had high confidence I won't say I
had the highest confidence when it came
to talking women I was just I was
confident in being funny and I knew that
women like funny guys so that always
just opened up the door for me but I was
[ __ ] Hurley I was [ __ ] at 13 which
it would just say you you started off
liking girls way more than guys or you
just start off [ __ ] guys it was about
the same
and then it was just like at the watch
the point I was like I like what they
got more so that's that you know it's
kind of this one so these numbers here
so about 49 percent of British guys
between the ages of 14 and 24 admitted
having having held themselves back from
asking someone out because they don't
have you know confidence it sucks I know
a lot of dudes go through that bouncer
just British or do they deal with this
in America I'm pretty sure but the
numbers I have here are specifically for
British that's um I don't understand
that cuz I go oh I like her so much I
need to know or I just at least getting
turned down what I would go oh she
doesn't like me now I could stop like
you her I can't take it I like her a lot
of people that don't even have like they
don't even think past that point isn't
it painful that you like someone for so
long and then you don't know and you're
just no confidence right this is a
multicultural multi multi ethnic issue
like no matter what country you're in
like this between all gender because me
too I remember at like having the
biggest crush on this kid in middle
school from like the end of 6th grade
all the way through like 8th grade I had
this crush on this one guy and you went
for three years with a minute yeah but
so it turned out that this guy later on
I find out that this guy also liked me
back but I didn't know whole you have a
boss to tell me and I didn't have the
balls to tell him and so I remember
after school and almost every day I
would tell my best friend crystal I'm
like okay crystal I didn't tell him
today but I'm gonna come tomorrow I have
to tell him because this is just driving
me [ __ ] crazy it's years
don't ever get the point where should I
go whatever [ __ ] yeah
should always be like okay tip you're
not gonna tell them like get over it I
hope she didn't just tell them for you
well I don't know probably I was like
that cuz I'm like no but then then this
this kid hands up getting this
girlfriend it knows it was really weird
cuz she ended up looking really similar
to me and then um but we were I was
friends with a girl too and I was just
like damn like you're so lucky you got
with him he's such a great guy and like
he's so cute or whatever and then but
then I later find out like I said that
he actually liked me the whole time and
I handed a beanie with this girl because
it was like Oh second bathroom she had
the balls to tell him you get look oh
and let me put a pin in that real quick
we're just talking about this on my
podcast yesterday women don't be taking
these shiny women don't take them you
weren't raised that way though I get it
I get it I wish I was raised that way to
go ahead get if you like that guy go get
but for me it was like you're coming off
way too strong you sound desperate
that's some hope but that goes for guys
too you can come up to some in Sunday oh
I bet you guys not raised that way
mm-hmm but but here's the thing so it's
it's over
we're raised to not follow girls this is
the thing it's difficult now because I
was host me to era post respect women
and no means no era how do you know when
to keep pursuing a female a young lady
versus respect her no we're just some
women play hard to get them like no ask
me again they need to learn some
something exactly they need to be more
cuz I don't know I was naive in college
I left a lot of vagina on the table
because I won I play you say no okay
cool and then also I'm like I'm not
gonna shoot my child again and then
unless you like help me looking crazy
again so I shoot once yeah I'm game
buzzer huh
no all right cool I'm out of here and
now let me though cuz I'm like for both
parties they should know like what
you're saying like you shoot your shot
didn't go through
okay then move on and then the girl
she's playing hard to get then that's
her turn to like come up to you exact
don't do it Isaiah girls both don't
always know exactly what they want so
they kind of need some coaxing or some
kind of like a push sometimes not
necessarily by the guy but maybe of our
friend like to kind of get give them
perspective into what they're seeking I
call [ __ ] and only because of this
most times in these situations when a
guy approaches a female God versus a
lady if they work together or they've
interacted at school together or they
see each other at a pub a lot you know
what that person's bring it to the table
personality-wise at least surface wise
right so you know personality wise you
know since the human why's you know
maybe you know what they do right so you
know what they bring it to the table so
if you tell that person know on that
first strike it's be like I'm not
interested in the things that your
interests we don't have similar likes
that type of thing you know so when you
say no that first time why do you need I
need a couple days to think about it not
saying it aloud but you think just
haven't need a couple days think about
it
you know what he actually is a good
catch maybe I will hit him up I hope he
asked me again versus you just doing it
you being proactive aside hey listen I
know I told you all the other day I was
going through something did you mind we
it's too dull I'm talking about an
adolescent age where you don't exactly
know what you want okay yes mostly
talking about so that's why I'm like I'm
remembering that mindset of like [ __ ]
dude I remember being like I think I
like this girl but I kind of like this
girl and I'm like I remember asking
girls out and then hearing later that
they actually did like me like [ __ ] like
that words like well I remember liking
girls and then being embarrassed that I
liked her because she wasn't even part
of the same group that we were in you
know what I mean like let's say like
you're like oh there's the jocks and
then there's a whatever and so I hung
out with like a bunch of like thugs and
stuff and there'd be girls that's I may
be part of like the ASB group and then
I'm like I would be embarrassed to even
let my friends know that I like a girl
that got good grades so much stupid [ __ ]
I just like girls with vaginas me too
but I was you know I like the girl who's
in track and field but I'm in computer
club and I was like you know she's never
she's never crossed off the computer
sure I never even seen a vagina until 17
or 16 in person it was important know in
real life and I've always had the
opportunity where the girls were always
freakier than me and I got scared
because the first time I was able to
almost get laid she came to school and
she was like I'm not wearing underwear
and I was thinking you want to ride the
bus a cup to my house she came over and
I was like let's do all role wait what I
mean you went further than most yeah I
was obviously I was like I'm a virgin
let me chill and she's probably thinking
you're a little [ __ ] you know and
that's the [ __ ] story of my life like
I never have to go like oh I need that
[ __ ] right because like the pros on
your lap its first time no no here's the
thing is like the first time I had a
girlfriend like he's like I would she
was my online girlfriend [ __ ] her
[ __ ] sister and her our sister's
boyfriend took us on a movie date we
were watching some [ __ ] right and then
and then we went to a different area to
sit down she started making out with me
she gave me a [ __ ] hickey grab my
hand put in her [ __ ] vagina and
that's what happened so I was like damn
dude I would say it was one chick in
college my freshman year in college who
like I was sexually experienced like I
had had sex a couple of times but I
wasn't like experienced on like a whole
lot of freaky [ __ ] this chick [ __ ] me
so good I was scared to that's scary
she [ __ ] me you understand me I could
never say yeah no no no no no her oh
yeah she [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me
okay like a literally scare me to the
planet I'm sorry at school and I just
when she was a dancer and so she knew a
lot of [ __ ] a lot of twerking moves she
gave me all in ways I didn't know was
possible she do it upside down and then
[ __ ] hit your head with the [ __ ]
foot no she does she [ __ ] you so good
that the skin from the bottom of your
dick ended up on the top of the dick Wow
made my balls darker myself lights
getting bored my balls now are that of
someone named or carrier why did they go
jerker
I don't I don't know I feel like there
you got a permanent Bruce hickey don't
beg guys just don't beg please no yeah
don't do that
okay only if you guys are actually
together that's kind of hot oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]